this is my orange coat well no it's not
really my orange coat right it's my new
orange coat my old orange coat is I
don't wear it as much anymore
this is a sad story
[Applause]
okay so it all starts in October 2016 is
and I were in Boston for the weekend and
we thought it was gonna be warm and it
was not warm so we're like oh let's go
try to find some jackets to stay warm
so we stumbled into a unique clove
Uniqlo is it unique lower unique glow
this is the emphasis on the first
syllable or the second Uniqlo Uniqlo
we're gonna hear all about in the
comments I'm just gonna keep saying
Uniqlo because even though I think
that's wrong
feels right and we find these down
jackets sitting on the wall exactly what
we needed
they were compressible and simple and
warm and there were really cool colors
and so we both bought one and we were
very happy and suddenly I started
wearing this jacket every day of my life
for like months and months and months
[Music]
I've bring it on trips I traveled and
did borders basically wearing that
jacket all the while I brought it to the
North Pole with me it was just it became
kind of a part of me because it was so
compressible I could just slip it
anywhere and I kind of fell in love
I love this jacket so much that when I
was in Tokyo shooting one of the borders
episodes I stumbled into like the Uniqlo
Mecca like eight stories seven stories
eight stories this Uniqua has eleven
stories twelve stories
and ended up buying another one of these
Checketts this time in grade which
honestly was one of the bigger mistakes
I've ever made and I'll tell you why in
a second PS I'm on my way to the
Norwegian mountains and need to go find
a grocery store to shop so we can cook
in this cabin I'm going out with some
buddies of mine so this jacket became
like really special to me the problem
was it was Uniqlo which is good stuff
but it's not you know last forever type
stuff I wore this thing kind of down to
the core the zippers started to get a
little bit worn down the seams were a
little bit weak and the color started to
fade so I thought man I love this jacket
so much that I will literally go like
purchase another one of these exact
jackets just start in continue to wear
it I just love it I love the color like
feel like an identity with this thing so
I walk in to a Uniqlo in Washington DC
only to find that they've changed the
design and the color of their down
jackets they now don't have any seams on
them which I really like the look of the
seams and they're not the same orange
they're different orange my heart sunk I
was like oh no so I looked at the
clearance rack it looked everywhere I
could not find this jacket and I was
very sad so so then for Christmas
my brother-in-law found a knockoff
totally fake version of this Uniqlo
jacket that's literally identical to the
one that I had with maybe a slightly
different color anyway he got it for me
came from China
was a total like ripoff like it even
said on the eBay thing like patented
Uniqlo
kote like they were like very upfront
with the fact that they were stealing
the patent now I had two of these coats
but unsurprisingly the Chinese knockoff
wasn't the best quality like it
definitely started to kind of wear down
as well
the water resistance just wasn't a thing
on it so I had the coat but it wasn't
really the coat it was very much a
knockoff version I finally decided if I
can't find this coat at Uniqlo the
original one I'm gonna have to look
somewhere else so I started looking at
Patagonia sure enough of how they go
neither they have a very similar coat a
similar color synthetic it's not down
but it's warm and it's water-resistant
all these things and I was super stoked
about it
so I put it in my cart I was about to
buy it and I go to buy it like a few
hours later and it sold out moments
after I had already added it to my cart
and it was in stock it became sold out
so I'm starting to realize that maybe I
need to rethink my whole strategy with
this orange coat obsession and so I'm
revealing now that I have purchased a
blue coat from Patagonia that is super
warm it's made of down
it is super robust it has a little
orange on it but it's not my original
orange coat karyam with Patagonia I like
the blue and then I got this water
resistant shell that is a nice beautiful
orange and that's how I'm reconciling
the tension in my psyche surrounding not
having my orange coat this orange coat
is actually waterproof like truly truly
waterproof like water would not go in it
it just beads up which is something I
need because I'm often out in the rain
Uniqlo if you're listening I would
definitely love to wear that old style
coat if you still have one in your
inventory somewhere send it my way I
will gladly replace it in two seconds if
I if I had an original
of that design to come look a
collector's item for me now okay time to
shop and then go into the mountains
[Music]